allora io sono un salentino ma sono
andato via dal salento a 18 anni sono
andato a studiata come poi in francia
quando sono andato via però mi sono
accorto da subito di una delle cose più
drammatiche era lo scontro di civiltà
fra la mia conservare le mie passate di
pomodoro e la passata industriale oppure
anche la scoperta dei supermercati i
forni a microonde possono sembrare delle
cose futili però poi piano piano invece
mi rendevo mi resi conto che invece
erano sostanziali erano sostanziali
perché io venivo da una terra
apparentemente sotto sviluppata negli
anni 70 80 il talento era ancora molto
arretrato forse per certi versi ancora
piene di contraddizioni di mafia e di
ingiustizia di povertà nelle campagne al
contrario le grandi città o addirittura
fuori dall'italia erano erano di luoghi
ricchi profondamente ricchi ma mi
accorgevo proprio e devo dire che questa
della passata industriale o la cosa
scongelata sono degli esempi poi
sostanziali che diventano dei luoghi
smemorati quindi io partivo da un luogo
pieno di contraddizioni ma con un
nocciolo di questioni attorno al cibo
piene di senso e andavo in luoghi pieni
di ricchezza quindi probabilmente hanno
ragione loro
ma smemorati e soprattutto che mangiano
male
questa è una questione che io non ho
ancora risolto però fu all'origine della
nascita di don pasta io el economista e
non certo punto non so per quale
misteriosa e sinapsi si costruì un
legame fra la memoria e le cose che
vivevo che erano l'amore per la musica
nacque funzione system divenni don pasta
e scrissi ma nel 2003 2004 da questo
primo testo che dico perché poi mi serve
per riflettere su una serie di cose che
era la parmigiana di melanzane che
associati a john coltrane i associato in
albo ogni volta una canzone non piatto
la parmigiana di melanzana la salentina
è la versione più pesante di quella
napoletana
ap de luca grande poeta insegna che le
melanzane rigorosamente di stagione
vanno seccate
dal 20 al sole per due giorni abitati in
città lasciate perdere
tagliate le melanzane con 9 con uno
spessore di un centimetro circa e
friggetele dopo averle passati nuove
farina è un passaggio importante perché
adesso ci sono dei nichilisti che non
friggono le melanzane per la parmigiana
perché loro pensano che questa cosa crea
sanità non rendendosi conto che c'era un
senso perché invece le melanzane devono
assorbe assorbire l'olio e il piatto è
più pesante perché deve essere più
pesante si fanno anche poi una quantità
indefinite di minuscole polpette di
carne anch'esse devono essere fritte
specifico per i nichilisti di prima e
con l'olio della frittura e si fa un
sugo la parmigiana è un piatto di agosto
per rispettare la stagionalità delle
melanzane e i pomodori d'abitudine noi
amiamo mangiarla il 15 agosto a pranzo
almeno devono fare 45 40 centigradi
altrimenti non si cominciano anche a
friggere ideale in spiaggia con la nonna
e dino negramaro caldo
quando diciamo tutti gli ingredienti
sono pronti si costruisce il castello di
melanzane prima alla base della teca è
cosparsa di olio e sugo con non si
incorra nelle matan jean e non si saprà
mai
traduco in modo che le melanzane poco
mente non s'incontrano al piatto e poi
si inseriscono compia nell'altro la
mozzarella e il sugo il basilico che
l'unico ingrediente del giro del piatto
il parmigiano e la trinità divina
l'unica in cui credo le polpettine una
spolveratina di uova lesse e una come si
dice a masterchef una julienne di
mortadella e tu ti pone la questione ma
chi è quel malato di mente che ha
inventato questa ricetta che ha ragione
c'era di attaccare i napoletani in
questo modo che la fanno leggera in un
certo senso anche se non avresti scono
le melanzane e perché un tempo bisognava
proteggersi e come ci si protegge si
costruisce una comunità e come si
costruisce una comunità si offre e meno
ai più offre cioè capite bene che io ho
fatto questa cosa della parmigiana non
per far vivere anche se famigliare
quando l'ho scritta io ero emozionato
pensavo al mio nonno alla memoria è però
fallito
e però per quattro elementi fondanti 1
la stagionalità due quella che adesso si
chiama filiera corta a chilometro zero
qualità ma mia nonna diceva
semplicemente li pubblicano il degente
guai i pomodori cioè non è che c'è
bisogno in uno scienziato per dire per
capire che i pomodori tira di qua e alla
fine del mondo per lei la definizione
geografica dispatch e quindi abbiamo
detto stagionalità e si va dal contadino
e che si rispetta il suo lavoro gusto
meraviglioso perché la pedagogia del
gusto la cosa fondante cioè se tu non
sai questo esercizio al gusto sono
intervita alla sapore delle fan pacioni
per esempio tu nun c'hai un esercizio
alle diversità dei gusti e poi amerai
solo un gusto e infine perché fa e la
cucina come dono il concetto di dono
perché tu non puoi concepire la cucina
in altro modo quantomeno io pensavo che
non si concepisce che in questo modo ma
non è così voi potete vedere tutto
tutto quello che viene detto adesso
quando del cibo e vi accorgerete che non
è così concetto di dono non esiste più
non esiste se non in modo molto filtrato
il concetto di stagionalità e il
concetto di filiera corta perché sono
ancora una volta degli esempi che
vengono dall'alto e questa cosa devo
spiegarla è stata detta
nell'anticipazione che cos'è una ricetta
una ricetta è una convenzione cioè
c'erano delle persone degli analfabeti
che parlavano in dialetto quindi a
utilizzavano solo il passaggio orale di
informazioni che passavano moralmente
l'informazione ma chi è come una facile
orecchiette con le rate e si
condividevano le informazioni fino a che
non si con non si arrivava un
compromesso compromesso convenzione
ricetta che non significa una tradizione
significa qualcosa che si evolve
attraverso lo scambio di informazioni
questa cosa qua ha alla base un elemento
fondante dell'intelligenza la deduzione
tu ci hai dei problemi
osservi e un certo punto capisci come
tutti voi e rientrare questa cosa questa
intelligenza come dal talismano della
felicità fino al cucchiaio d'argento
fino a passare i programmi attuali si
concepisce la cucina intanto come un
atto in cui la qualità tra dice qualcun
altro poi che la ricetta sono dei
precetti precetti e procedure fai così e
metti tanto ma tu a quando parte dalla
nonna che non sa come se pace
esattamente regolate quanto basta cioè
dellai il concetto di intelligenza e tu
ti accorgi che piano piano una delle più
grandi tragedie non è tanto la perdita
della tradizione della memoria perché se
non si consiglia dalla memoria come un
atto di intelligenza collettiva di
persone che non avevano nulla e che però
sapevano risolvere i problemi in modo
intelligente condividendo le
informazioni allora tutte queste cose
non sono possibili io sto girando le
campagne i contadini pescatori e gli
chiedo come loro possono fare allora
mostra questi video poi i giovani mi
dicono
riusciamo più a concepire la cucina in
quel modo e poi ci sono tutte queste
cose drammatiche che si sentono attorno
al mondo del cibo alle passate di
pomodoro a 50 cm centesimi che non solo
fanno schifo ma poi sono raccolte sono
frutto di raccolta di pomodori da
schiavi trasportati dalla mafia e
venduti da supermercati che si
trascinano i contadini che compaiono
tutta questa serie di cose hanno un
senso se si si si paragonano di fronte a
questa cosa bellissima che la passata
fatto in casa ed è per questo che io mi
sono posto la questione si sia ancora
possibile e sempre più mi sono accorto
che non è possibile non è possibile
perché non si può sperare semplicemente
legiferando che i contadini i giovani
vadano alla parata a terra perché le
regole non permettono a più di lavorare
la terra in modo economico perché adesso
c'era una una delle cose più belle che
dallo scambio di sementi fra i contadini
di un luogo ancora una volta scambio di
intelligenza non lo scambio impossibile
vietato per legge devi prenderti le
sementi industriali e quindi rime
dimentica i medicinali medicine
industriali e tutta questa serie di cose
che ritorna dalla questione fondante ti
tolgo l'intelligenza si chiama dia
nazione marziana non ti permette di
pensare e i giovani non ce la fanno non
ce la fanno i contadini non ce la fanno
i pastori io non so se vi ricordate il
profumo del caglio della ricotta ognuno
di poi qua dentro immagino la sentita
non è più possibile non è più possibile
utilizzare il caglio in quel modo tutta
una serie di regole c'è una legge una
legge surreale che non ti permette di
portare i dolci fatti in casa nelle
scuole per i propri bambini e quindi
devi mangiare dolci nella plastica
avvolti nella plastica sono informazioni
fondamentali su come va il mondo
qual è la soluzione probabilmente non
c'è loro sono più forti e i piccoli
contadini sono più piccoli e tutte le
organizzazioni economiche sto fanno sì
che loro non ce la faranno
ma chi significa che loro non ce la
faranno che noi mangeremo meno bene ma
se un americano magari non è già meno
bene magari non se ne accorge ma noi ci
abbiamo un patrimonio sconcertante
chiamato in ogni parte del mondo
che c'è un senso allora mi sono posto la
questione di come si può risolvere il
problema attraverso la responsabilità di
ognuno di riacquisita della propria
memoria e alla fine di questo lungo
viaggio che fu acquisite mills per
questo lungo viaggio in giro per
l'italia a raccogliere ricette delle
nonne scrissi questo testo che vive che
mi permetto di dirti mangiare è come
respirare senza timore io non potevo
raccontare la cucina italiana da solo
non ne sarei stato in grado perché
corale e la cucina italiana
avevo paura prima di iniziare paura che
tutto si fosse perso di una cucina che
nessuno ha più il tempo o la voglia di
fare che a mio figlio non potessi
lasciare nulla in dono del mio essere
uomo e di sud e uomo e d'italia come
pellegrino artusi a cui mi sono ispirato
ho cominciato a esplorare l'italia piano
piano domandando a tutti ma ti è come la
faci come si fa questo come si fa a
quest'altra ed è stato bello ricevere
ricette senza g senza indicazioni
precise e dovevo scrivere un libro
signore mi puoi dire esattamente le dosi
quanto basta quanto ne piglia a nessuno
interessava darmi delle indicazioni
precise ma tutti interessava darmi le
parole belle che ognuno ha raccontato
alla cucina della propria storia in
quelle lettere non c'era niente di
patetico malinconico tradizionalista non
c'era qualcosa di questa idea di memoria
scomparsa perché la memoria abbiamo
visto è viva perché serve perché
dobbiamo renderci tutti conto assieme se
vale la pena conservare un patrimonio
infinito o vederlo scomparire
a furia di reinventare alleggerire
infiocchettare e fate riduzioni di
scalogno
che il cibo resti linguaggio di ognuno
che ci si raccolga in ogni istante della
storia che c'è dietro patrimonio fatto
di donne che hanno raccolto riso
nell'acqua e pomodori sotto il sole e
hanno fatto figli grandi e grossi a mio
figlio ogni bimbo e bimba che sappiano
che una delle rivolte più belle e quelle
di non essere mai uguali agli altri e
che per farlo è bello conservare ogni
singola traccia della diversità della
cucina italiana che abbiamo ricevuto in
dono che lo strumento più prezioso che
abbiamo ricevuto per sapere che nella
vita non bisogna omologarsi mai mai
passivamente alle regole alle abitudini
alle leggi imposta talvolta stupide e
alla globalizzazione dei gusti che ogni
cosa cancella perché la cucina italiana
ci ha aiutato a vivere con dignità nella
disoccupazione disoccupazione nelle
guerre durante regimi infami e fascisti
nelle migrazioni durante i terremoti e
nella fame assumetevi la responsabilità
della polstrada memoria proteggiamoci e
soffriggete
[Applauso]